tae Joon is doing his best to save the
planet or at least part of it this pond
tae Joon is learning about environmental
preservation and sustainability on the
agenda today how frogs survive in ponds
this is the green school on the
Indonesian island of Bali the bamboo
paradise is located around a quarter of
an hour south of the small city of ubud
there's no central school building
instead individual classrooms are spread
across an eight hectare campus some of
the lessons for instance in green
studies take place outdoors I told them
like this is my pond I want them to fix
it up and I gave them sort of some
demands we've been studying the pond for
two weeks and we learned that the frogs
are dying in here because there's no
escape routes this gravel will allow the
frogs to reach land solar panels provide
eighty percent of the school's power the
rest comes from a bio gas generator that
uses composting toilets along with
ecology related subjects the school also
offers standard courses in math grammar
philosophy in physics the students come
from almost 40 different countries the
curriculum is internationally certified
right now in science class we're doing a
physics sort of a lab / which I call it
design engineering Pratt yes we're doing
a whole project where we have to build a
roller coaster and made out of rotten
and Bamber they have time and space to
be creative with the bamboo with the
return with each other and the whole
group dynamic piece it's just a much
more thematic approach to teaching than
you would get in a
ah school after recess it's time for
math but class begins with in israeli
folk dance there's so many kinesthetic
aspects that i can teach through the
photons moving forward moving backwards
keeping a beat stepping to the right
step into the left all amazing skills
which are for our human body that's a
sustainable education it's an education
for human beings not for universities
tuition costs around 10,000 euros a year
Balinese families can't afford that so
the green school remains in oasis for
the children of wealthy foreigners still
maybe one day they will share the
ecological knowledge they learned here
back in their home countries